and this is why we keep going back to
responsibility the responsibility of
having that child without the authority
over it it's not a fair deal for men
it's the same thing with women having
the responsibility of looking after a
woman but not any authority over her
that it's not it's not a fair deal and
so my question is can we really blame
the men for not wanting to date single
mothers can we really blame the men for
not wanting to date older women and all
the problems that come with it I
personally think no and I think we
should really warn younger women that if
you get pregnant you've really made your
bed and your chance of having a
successful relationship after being a
single mother is low because one men
aren't going to want to date you and
even if they do it comes with these type
of problems